[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue d'un point de
vue très heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce premier rendez vous de la semaine je
vous propose de découvrir en images le
sommaire de cette émission nous allons
revenir sur l'intervention du président
de la république hier soir sur france 2
à ces nouvelles sur la forme mais
était-elle aussi novatrice sur le fond
nous allons en parler avec nos invités
comme nous parlerons des mesures
gouvernementales concernant les migrants
et des consignes du ministre de
l'intérieur pour aller contrôler les
migrants hébergés dans les hôtels
sociaux demande qui provoque un certain
nombre de réactions et de critiques
nous parlerons aussi de la république en
marche à l'occasion de la publication
dans le figaro de ce matin d'un sondage
où on voit le parti du président de la
république
écraser tout le reste du paysage
politique français
tout cela est il crédible réaliste nous
en parlerons et enfin nous parlerons de
la vignette est ce son grand retour
l'état comme d'habitude a besoin
d'argent a vraiment pour entretenir les
routes et voilà qu'on va revenir cette
petite musique d'une d'une taxe sur les
automobiles qui permettrait d'entretenir
le réseau routier nous allons parler de
ces quatre sujets avec des invités qui
ont bien voulu nous rejoindre bonsoir
françois sureau bonsoir vous êtes
écrivain avocat au conseil d'état la
cour de cassation
votre dernier livre pour la liberté et
répondre au terrorisme par la raison a
été publié il ya quelques mois
maintenant aux éditions tallandier pour
soir pascal perrineau bonsoir vous êtes
politologue professeur à l'institut
d'études politiques de paris est aussi
président de l'association des anciens
élèves de cet établissement d'ailleurs
est votre livre cette france de gauche
qui votent fn a été publié au seuil
cette année aussi
bonsoir yves thréard
il est directeur adjoint des rédactions
du figaro éditorialistes presque
quotidiens et à des masters du toc en
tout cas on vous a retrouvé ce matin
dans les colonnes du figaro et
animateurs du tour entre autres et
intervenant régulier aussi sur rtl dans
l'émission on refait le monde comme jean
christophe buisson directeur adjoint
mais lui du figaro magazine également
historien et auteur du livre 1917
l'année qui a changé le monde qui a été
publié en fin d'année dernière aux
éditions perrin parlons des manuels
macron de l'intervention du président de
la république c'était hier soir sur
france 2 macron roi en son palais avant
du titre et cette partie du débat
d'abord un mot sur le sur le style
présidentiel et sur cet usage assez
inhabituel il faut bien le dire de la
troisième personne du singulier pour
parler de lui regardez en décidant au
mois de mai dernier d'élire un président
de 39 ans qui n'avait aucun parti que
personne ne connaissait et qui sortait
de nulle part
ce qui est le choix que notre pays ait
fait ça dit la haine qu'il a pour votre
serviteur
bon je la lui laisse qu'il vive avec ça
fera son quotidien
les gens qui s'opposent pour ou insulter
ou décrétées donc un intérêt face et
david c'est le commentaire politique
mais ça n'intéresse pas président de la
république alors vous avec un petit
extrait la pression d'un public faisait
allusion alors en vo qui a ses propos
assez critique
plus globalement pascal paradoxe que
vous avez pensé de cette intervention
on a dit qu'elle était originale parce
que le président se déplaçait d'un
bureau à l'autre dans l'escalier puis
dans le hall de l'elysée mais sur le
fond est ce que vous avez appris des
choses non sur le fond c'était une mise
en musique de multiples réformes mesures
qui ont été prises dans les mois les
mois précédents et il les a mises en
musique qu'ils les amis c'est une
vieille démarche emmanuel macron il
disait au fond le gros problème des
présidents précédents c'est l'absence de
mise en ce sens et là hier soir il y
avait une volonté de mettre tout ça en
perspective en restant à un niveau de
généralité
en effet extrêmement élevé mais si vous
voulez
itinérances de l'interview ne se prêtait
pas en effet à aller au fond il y avait
très peu d'effet d'annoncé à part une ou
deux mesures même une
il n'y a pas eu d'effet d'annoncé ce qui
a pu décevoir mais moi j'ai été surpris
par une relative simplicité du thon un
côté direct dans les changes qui venait
un peu contrarié le côté très jupitérien
que emmanuel macron avait voulu donner
jusqu alors à l'exercice de la fonction
présidentielle vous trouvez que
l'extrait qu'on a publié afin qu'on a
donné avec un peu de malice sur
l'étudiant du président parlant du la
13e personne du singulier n'étaient pas
représentatives n'est pas représentatif
de prévention il y avait une certaine
familiarité ne serait ce que dans les
échanges pas simplement verbaux mais
quasi corporelle entre laurent
delahousse delahousse et le président de
la république et pas trop si dans le
génome lui par les questions qui lui
étaient posées assure bien sûr il n'y
avait pas de mise en danger mais la
forme même de l'interview ne se prêtait
pas à cela
il y avait plutôt en effet une volonté
de remettre ans perd en perspective et
de remettre en sens et de lutter contre
un élément qui commençaient à apparaître
tout même dans les enquêtes d'opinion
c'est l'aspect autoritaire du président
de la république un emmanuel macron dit
qu'il est au dessus en effet de toutes
ces enquêtes d'opinion mais quand vous
regardez les enquêtes d'opinion j'allais
dire pour le président ça baigne comme
disent les jeunes sont bonnes ça baigne
mais sauf sur deux points
l'autoritarisme et l'absence de
proximité avec les gens et j'ai remarqué
qu'ils hier sur ces deux terrains il y
avait une volonté d'aller un peu à
contre courant à la fois de
l'autoritarisme et de l'absence de
proximité que l'on prête à emmanuel
macron sensations parce que vous avez
été vous aussi séduits par cette
proximité passagers pas la télé alors
j'ai pas dit non mais mais s'avère ai
parlé mardi l'émission que vous n'avez
pas vu moi je ne vous aime pas non je
suis comme vous tous ces faits c'est
notre métier commun un bon
non mais je vais quand même dire quelque
chose quand même après je vais même
aller voir des extraits j'avais vu un
peu à quoi ça ressemble on peut dire
sans être sains et frais que vous
connaissez assez bien le président de la
république
oui enfin nous sommes plusieurs dans ce
cas là j'imagine
non il ya plus de choses qui m'ont
frappé la première chose c'est que
d'abord c'est le côté pascalien de
l'interview le le monde mac rognant est
un monde dans lequel le centre est
partout et la circonférence nulle part
d'où cette circulation actuellement
permanente à l'intérieur des lieux
montrant que comme un fluide
le président de la république s'infiltre
partout le deuxième élément qui est à
mon avis appartient au registre
télévisuelle d'une chose que j'adore
peut-être vous aussi ils sont les séries
télévisées
c'est netflix et west wing vous avez
remarqué que les gens ne s'arrêtent
jamais dans un bureau pour discuter de
choses essentielles mais au contraire
parcours la totalité de l'espace dans
l'espoir que cette marche de manière
assez qu'ancienne les rendra plus
intelligent par voie de conséquence
rendra également le spectateur pu
l'arrêter l'école
donc je suis abonnée sais pas si on peut
donner ses trucs que je suis abonné à
des chaînes spécifiques et dans laquelle
on peut voir une vidéo live voilà donc
trois histoires d'eaux claires le leader
le deuxième élément c'est ça et ça me
paraît très révélateur de cette espèce
d'idée moderne selon lequel le pouvoir
n'est pas dans un grand bureau avec des
gars qui ont des têtes de sous préfet
dramatique mais au contraire circulent
dans le cadre d'une conversation
bilatérales c'est le pouvoir comme
conversation est en fait en troisième
lieu je lave ou macron là dessus c'est
la réincarnation du roi babar alors il
faut peut-être l'expliquent un peu je
tiens personnellement que le roi baba
est la figure secrète de la vie
politique française
l'archétype absolue la personne cachée
d'un roi à la fois présents et absents
choisi par le peuple est distinct de lui
et qui en réalité est un roi absolument
centrale puisque à la fois il met en
oeuvre une société parfaite tout en en
étant raisonnablement absents et surtout
à partir d'un élément très présent dans
l'interview qu'elle élément moral vous
ce n'est qu'à la fin du songe de babar
l'idée centrale c'est que l'exercice de
l'action publique consiste à conjurer
les passions mauvaise du peuple la
tristesse la haine le dégoût la paresse
une très large part de l'exercice
politique macro nhien consiste moins à
prendre des décisions il en prend par
ailleurs mais a tenté par la parole de
conjurer comme babar dans son rêve les
passions aux mauvaises du peuple et
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
circulation à l'intérieur du palais de
céleste ville m'est apparue absolument
symbolique qui s'appuie sur vous qui
n'avez pas d'hostilité de principe à
l'égard de l'idée monarchique
cette jolie maintenant vu entièrement
d'accord avec ce que ce que dit françois
mais je pense qu'à pas besoin de
remonter aux années brunhoff la barre il
faut remonter à ce qui est l'essence de
la vème république et une constitution
totalement monarchique on sait très bien
le rôle qui a joué un petit peu pierre
boutang qui était qui était monarchique
avec michel debré pour faire cette
constitution considérant que les
français finalement avait un vieux fond
monarchique et dieu sait si emmanuel
macron l'a répété à de nombreuses
reprises qu'il avait le sentiment que
les français n'avaient pas tout à fait
faire le deuil de de n'avoir coupé la
tête de louis saez et que finalement le
régime monarchique correspondrait peu ou
prou à au peuple français
donc emmanuel macron il intègre cette
notion il la modernise avec avec l'idée
que cette incarnation du monarque
républicain a été mal faite et sous
nicolas sarkozy et surtout sur françois
hollande qui était en dessous de tout et
qui reprend à son compte toute la
symbolique monarchie qu'il a faite le
jour de sa notamment le jour de son
investiture le jour de son nez de son
élection et en même temps et françois
souray mille fois raison il intègre
quelque chose d'ultra moderne qui est la
communication par l'image et notamment
par la série télévisée ou le cinéma
le la façon dont ils étaient filmés hier
relevait effectivement du cinéma ou la
série télé c'est avec des plans
incroyables des des plans de coupe total
très audacieux surtout prêt pour la télé
publique
donc ça il fait ces deux choses là mon
avis quelque chose qui corresponde
vraiment un vieux fond français dans
l'adn et qui est absolument non dit est
quelque chose de très contemporain qui
est le rôle de l'image la stratégie de
la communication par l'image ce qui est
central dans la barre études
philosophiques fort philosophie
politique c'est que en réalité cette
idée c'est que la république ne parvient
pas pas un seul principe par son seul
principe liberté égalité fraternité à
assurer l'égalité entre les personnes
mais qu'en revanche la condensation de
l'espace politique dans la personne du
roi babar arrive à rendre les français
frères entre eux et c'est exactement
l'exercice à quoi nous sommes en train
de semer parlant définir ce qui donne un
tout petit peu inquiétant c'est qu'on a
parlé beaucoup de formes effectivement
sur le fond il n'y avait strictement
rien je vais à part annoncé qu'on avait
gagné la guerre contre l'état islamique
en l'occurrence ou plutôt les rues c'est
bachar al assad que nous et que c'est
immonde allait mettre des éoliennes en
quantité et que nicolas hulot était et
nicolas hulot tête un homme inquiet on
le reste on n'a pas eu vraiment beaucoup
d'informations à ce que vous partagez
cette cette frustration à ce que vous
l'aurez interrogé comme ça avoue le
professional public ou est ce que vous
auriez été plus à fond ses enjeux
bon j'ai souvent tendance est un peu
trop offensif mais vous aurez plusieurs
remarques à faire moi d'abord je sais
pas si c'est président de la république
qui était interviewé aussi c'était lors
de la housse parfois je me pose la
question de savoir qui est l
intervieweur et interviewé il y avait
une mise en scène du journaliste comme
on a rarement eu quand même nom même
niveau que l'on met dans les moteurs et
à bien jouer de cette façon
deuxième chose je me pose la question
pour moi je suis j'ai la prétention
d'être au fait un peu des dossiers je
suis ça tous les jours
mais le fait de marcher l'être dans une
espèce de séquences les journées du
patrimoine vous savez où vous balader
dans un palais le fait de marcher est ce
que vous regardez pas plus l'image que
vous n'écoutez le fonds est à mon avis
il ya énormément de français parce que
nous évidemment on est en vente dans des
tons temps-là savoir est ce qu'il va
faire une annonce qu est-ce qui va dire
et tout ça je pense qu'il ya énormément
de français qui ont plus regardé le
décor la réalisation vous avez des
clairs obscurs vous avez des flous
vous avez la pendule c'est très joli
mais vous oubliez complètement ce que le
président de la république ça c'est là
une ambiance puisqu'un disait oui mais
c'est une ambiance et d'ailleurs je dois
dire pour bien connaître que laurent
delahousse est très forts pour ça pour
créer des ambiances des ambiances qui se
doit
troisième chose et j'ai bien aimé la
chronique de guillaume tabard notre
abily en ta maman le figaro ce matin la
première chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit quand j'ai regardé c'est tout
de suite portia giscard d'estaing
giscard d'estaing mais c'est essayer
d'innover en nous présentant son épouse
lors des voeux je sais plus en quelle
année c'était ça devait être en 75 et là
c'est encore une innovation on va c'est
une innovation il ya beaucoup de choses
en commun entre macro et giscard
d'estaing et c'est une innovation est ce
que cette innovation ne va pas être
ressenti par beaucoup de français comme
quelque chose de pompeux de décaler
complètement décalé et d'inapropriée à
l'exercice politique
je m'entends ce que veulent les français
et il a dit d'ailleurs c'est pas les
commentaires de laurent wauquiez dont
ils ont rien à faire c'est de
l'efficacité des résultats et c'est pas
des mises en scène tels que c'est je
dirais que ce qu'a fait hier macron
c'est tout l'inversé de l'objectif de
ses discours ses discours c'est de dire
vous voulez des résultats
vous voulez une forme épurée de
l'exercice du pouvoir
il a montré tout le contraire hier alors
je suis très dubitatif je suis d'accord
là dessus qui dit un petit peu la même
chose que vous chérif traire c'est
l'ancienne garde des sceaux et maire du
7e arrondissement de paris rachida dati
c'était ce matin sur france info écoutez
pas c'était la journée du patrimoine
hier pour l'élysée donc non mais c'était
sympathique c'est bien il parle de lui
parle de sa vision des choses
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était plus une
expression philosophie que l'actuel
pourquoi pas eu d'accord pourquoi pas
mais quand on est président de la
république et qu'on a un chômage de
masse extrêmement important quand il ya
des inégalités regarder le rapport qui
vient de sortir et quelques jours en
disant que les inégalités n'ont jamais
aussi forte dans notre pays il ya
peut-être des urgences qui sont encore
plus importantes que simplement sa
petite personne de juin pascal vanhove à
ce qu'elles étaient décalés par rapport
aux apprentis aux attentes des français
écoutez la question du chômage qui
évoque rachida dati il l'a évoqué il a
évoqué en disent en effet qu'il y avait
là des enjeux les plus décisifs sur
lequel on ne pouvait pas se prononcer en
ce moment qu'il fallait juger le chômage
sur deux ans et que dans deux en effet
on pourrait se prononcer sur le chômage
reprenant d'ailleurs un élément qui
était un élément qu'on a retourné comme
même s'il a été plus prudent vis-à-vis
de françois hollande à un françois
hollande qui prenait sans cesse des
engagements là l'engagement est plus
floue cependant il a dit aux français
hier on peut s'attendre à des résultats
de ma politique de la politique que j'ai
mise en place à l'horizon à l'horizon 2
ans donc rachida dati est un peu un peu
sévère sur ce point la rive
oui oui ça lui arrive et pas simplement
avec emmanuel macron mais avec les siens
également donc je dirais non ce qui
était intéressant hier aussi c'est que
dans le maquereau nice mais il ya en
effet des éléments de modernité évidente
et puis il ya des éléments presque de
retour aux origines de retour aux
origines de la vème république il ya des
éléments où il a installé et réinstaller
l'éloignement du pouvoir qui était un
des éléments de stratégie qu'avait
adoptée en effet françois mitterrand
quand il découvre la fonction
présidentielle
et en cela il était hier à la fois dans
son rôle de président distant mais il
invitait au travers en effet de ceux de
ses très belles images il invitait le
peuple français j'allais dire à m l'oeil
au trou de la serrure de l'elysée et à
rentrer au coeur du palais présidentiel
je trouve ça pas pas malhabile lorsqu'on
peut dire en tout cas c'est que cet
exercice du pouvoir lui réussit plutôt
bien regarder parce que comme on l'est
on les donne toujours l'un après l'autre
la tendance d'aidé de la courbe
d'opinion et de popularité du président
de la république depuis son arrivée à
l'elysée il ya eu des débuts
difficile mais depuis septembre il se
passe vraiment quelque chose il a quand
même gagné 10 points en deux mois ce qui
est quand même relativement conséquent
je passe sous le contrôle du politologue
pascal perrineau en effet ça ne s'est
jamais vu auparavant une telle reprise
le début c'est de plus en plus classique
un classique
c'est en effet une lune de miel
extrêmement éphémère et puis ensuite la
descente aux enfers avec presque aucune
capacité à se rattraper dans cette
descente aux enfers là on voit comment
assez rapidement à partir du mois
d'octobre
il reprend pied il reprend pied mais
c'est extrêmement intéressant de voir ce
qui s'est passé il y a eu dans le
macrocosme électorale de moments il ya
d'abord le moment électoral où ils
sèment le désordre à gauche de manière
extraordinaire et ou le maquereau nisme
c'est et de gauche et du centre
mais c'est pas et de gauche et de droite
mais ensuite une fois qu'il est au
pouvoir et ça se continue aujourd'hui
avec toutes les mesures qu'il a prises
sur le terrain économique et social et
qu'il s'apprête à prendre sur le terrain
regalia il s'est attaqué à la droite et
ils s'aiment un désordre dans
l'électorat de droite gigantesque et
envahir cette remontée c'est l'électorat
bien sûr dans là on l'a bien vu valentin
pilar du figaro.fr nous a rejoint
bonsoir valentin ont certes mission est
aussi interactif que possible et
vous êtes penché sur les réactions des
internautes à l'intervention
présidentielle ou presque royale d'hier
soir royal c'est le monarque roi
souverain
bref j'ai vraiment tout vu hier sur
twitter notamment ce tweet illustré
voilà comment on pouvait qualifier
l'entrée en scène d'emmanuel macro hier
sur twitter par ce tweet de manu quand
on peut voir là l'écran mais au final
que retiennent aux internautes
et bien pas grand chose avec ce
commentaire de cet internaute pas grand
chose en dehors je suis le plus beau le
plus intelligent le meilleur je suis le
plus grand expert en auto cirage de
pompes vraiment les commentaires y aller
à fond
on a également cet autre commentaire on
avait on avait eu moi je maintenant on à
moi moi moi moi moi je je je je je
vaste progression renchérit cet
internaute plus pragmatique on à gaby
macron est plus attiré par le destin de
la france et sa propre gloire que par le
bien être des français
nous n'avons plus rien à attendre de
notre leone et au pardon louis xiv
enfin france 2 est également pointée du
doigt pour un entretien qualifié de trop
complaisant sur la forme il vous le
disiez tout à l'heure notamment sur ce
décor où on les voit en mouvement
constamment été critiqué sur la forme et
la presse anglo saxonne n'a pas manqué
dans la pomme manqué une pour critiquer
cette interview comme ce journaliste de
reuters
son tweet a été l'un des plus réduites
et de la soirée plus de trois mille fois
où il twittait qu'ironie une des
questions les plus pertinentes
percutante de cette interview voici
l'arbre de noël dans la cour c'est la
fin de l'année que voulez-vous dire aux
français n'ayez pas peur
il faisait référence à ces révolutions
économiques dont citer qu'eux n'ont
parlé laurent delahousse
voilà je terminerais que ce commentaire
qui résume plus ou moins à la tonalité
qui avait sur les réseaux hier celui de
georges toujours de la com attirant
l'attention du téléspectateur sur le
nouveau style d'interview et non sur le
contenu s'assurant à votre commentaire
juste un mot je n'étais pas du tout des
choristes disait yves tout à l'heure je
pense qu'au contraire il fait là
exactement ce qu'il fait depuis le début
mai et de manière répétitive le discours
au congrès également un vide de toute
mesure pratique
en fait je pense pour leur gueule
oula j'ai oublié de l'ajouter d'accord
alors depuis qu'il est président il fait
exactement ça c'est vrai on a
l'impression que pour lui le lieu
présidentielle et en ce sens c'est aller
au monarchique si je veux dire que lieu
présidentielle c'est le lieu de la
synthèse nationale et celui de la
synthèse nationalité la fois personnel
politique morale esthétique passionnel
et c'est le lieu de la santé national
pour le reste il nomme un premier
ministre il actionne une majorité il ya
des ministres qui prennent des mesures
techniques dont le cas échéant il se
prévaut mais avec une certaine distance
je pense que le président hollande
aurait fait ce que mâcon à frais en
matière de droit du travail
on en aura eu les oreilles absolument
gonflé alors que là ce n'est pas le cas
du tout il est clair que pour lui le la
parole élyséenne l'action eli zen c'est
avant tout l'action de réalisation de
cette espèce de synthèse nationale
invisible quitte à laisser d'autres
poursuivre des politiques en apparence
d'ailleurs assez distinctes comme celle
de colons qui ne correspond pas du tout
à ce qu'il dit c'est pendant sa campagne
et d'autres du même type autorise passe
et potestas ce temps même temps incarné
par là par la même figure royale moi je
serais lui j'aurais même pu fêter mon
anniversaire à chambrer pendant que j'y
suis pas savoir pourquoi pas vous
parliez à l'instant de l'action du
ministre de l'intérieur gérard collomb
peut-être faisiez-vous allusion à ses
récentes initiatives concernant les les
demandeurs d'asile c'est aujourd'hui la
journée internationale des migrants et
on parle beaucoup d'une demande faite il
ya quelques jours par le ministre de
l'intérieur avec la constitution des
équipes mobiles des préfectures pour
aller contrôler les migrants dans les
hôtels sociaux et notamment ceux qui
sont en situation avec les règles ne
sont pas susceptibles de profiter du
droit d'asile
il ya eu des critiques là dessus
notamment celles du défenseur des droits
mais le ministre de l'intérieur assume
sa position écouter le c'était ce matin
chez nos confrères d'rtl
nous avons 95 mille demandes d'asile par
an ça veut dire une grande ville chaque
année si évidemment nous accueillons
tout le monde nous ne pourrions pas
accueillir dans de bonnes conditions
dans les hôtels j'ai ici des personnes
qui sont là depuis quinze ans qu'on n'a
jamais sorti de cette situation c'est
les et ceux qui vont aller dans ces
centres vont effectivement placé de
manière à ce que ces gens puissent soit
s'insérer dans notre société
s'ils y ont droit soient effectivement
être éloigné engagé dans l'aide aux
demandeurs d'asile comment est-ce que
vous réagissez face à ces propos tu es
bien je réagi de manière nuancée
parce qu'avant tout je suis comme
beaucoup d'autres dans mon cas un
fervent défenseur de l'asile et que tous
fervents défenseurs de l'asile
malgré ce qu un assez grand nombre
d'associations peuvent en dire ont pu
constater que pour des raisons
historiques notamment la fermeture des
frontières à l'immigration normal nos
nazis l'air que l'asile avait été très
largement
détournée de son objet initial et je
pense qu'il est honnête pour tous
défenseurs de l'asile attaché à une
défense
dans mon cas fanatique de ce droit de ne
pas se voiler la face face à la réalité
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je vois
ce qui est en train de se passer avec
une certaine tristesse puisqu'en réalité
le débat asilaire est en train d'être
complètement captée par l'opposition des
deux forces qui sont incapables de le
résoudre
un assez grand nombre d'associations qui
en réalité présente et je peux très bien
comprendre sur le plan humain par
ailleurs une option de type
immigrationniste selon laquelle tout le
monde a vocation à céder accueillir un
crew l'accueil inconditionnel sans
frontiérisme le sans frontiérisme et
mais je peux très bien comprendre un sur
le plan philosophique c'est une option
qui serait plus dans la mienne et ab en
tout cas en politique je comprends très
bien qu'elles puissent être tenus mais
elle ne me paraît pas susceptible
d'aboutir à un règlement efficace du
problème et de l'autre cette idée
absolument classique en france qu en
réalité l'asie n'est qu'une variable de
la politique de l'immigration et le
domaine administratif du ministre de
l'intérieur par ailleurs chargé de la
police des étrangers ce qui fait que
alors que je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
droit d'asile sans reconduite
pas de droit d'asile sans réduction des
délais le simple fait de confier cette
réforme et sa gestion et sa mise en
oeuvre au ministre de la police est de
nature à priver cette action de toute
légitimité
c'est pour ça que ma position depuis le
début mais elle est partagée par
quelques-uns mais elle n'est pas
largement pas majoritaires c'est que je
pense que cette politique qui a de bons
et de mauvais aspects gagnerait à être
mises en oeuvre par une autorité
réellement indépendante dont
l'attachement au droit de l'asile ne
serait pas incontestable
ce qui n'est par ailleurs pas le cas du
ministre de l'intérieur puisque d'une
certaine manière vous savez que les gens
qui plaide sur ces affaires sont
absolument habitués moi je trouve ça
assez normal qu'on renvoie des gens qui
ont demandé l'asile et qui ne satisfont
pas aux critères de l'asile mais tout le
travail des fonctionnaires du ministère
l'intérieur depuis une dizaine d'années
consiste à empêcher les gens de même
présenté une demande d'asile
raison pour laquelle il a tant
d'annulations par les tribunaux
administratifs et par les juridictions
administratives
et si vous laissez tout ce passif cette
impression de dédain de la grandeur du
droit d'asile qui à mon avis rend le
ministre de l'intérieur inaudible
lorsqu'il dit des choses qui sur un
centre de ces deux sujets sont fondées
je vous prends un exemple très simple
c'est le problème des dublin
2 qui s'appelle maintenant des dublin 3
vous avez en france dans les foyers je
n'ai pas des gens qui ont été du tas de
manières qui ont fait une demande
d'asile en allemagne la demande d'asile
a été rejetée par l'allemagne pays
sérieux qui contrairement à la grèce
examine sérieusement les demandes
d'asile et qui viennent ensuite tenté
leur chance
il est assez clair hélas c'est toujours
très difficile quand on s'occupe d'asile
de parler de ça de manière générale sans
considération des situations humaines
mais il est assez clair que ils doivent
rentrer en allemagne où l'allemagne doit
se charger de la reconduite il est tout
à fait inacceptable qu'il vienne ici au
béret un budget de l'accueil de l'asile
et du traitement des demandes d'asile et
de l'insertion des réfugiés qui est déjà
en grand péril
voilà c'est la raison pour laquelle
hélas dans cette affaire rien ne le
satisfait les parts non mais la
structure dont vous parlez qu'elle
quelles seraient ses moyens techniques
financiers pour pour mener à bien ses
investigations s'il ya que la police qui
perd ses moyens d'attaqués en d2 et
celle cela tu veux avoir des moyens de
froid ça je crois qu'on parle de
plusieurs choses différentes
ce qui me paraît absolument central
c'est que d'une certaine manière
pourquoi est ce que le problème se pose
à l'heure actuelle le problème se pose
parce que les délais la complexité des
laits l'engorgement dans la région
parisienne en particulier en très très
difficile les mécanismes de de
raccourcissement d'examens de contrôle
et de renvoi c'est la raison pour
laquelle à mes yeux la seule bonne
solution c'est d'une manière de
régionaliser l'office français de
protection et apatrides de procéder
comme font les allemands d y aura des
répartitions géographiques qui serait
sûr du d'assignation à résidence dans
les régions de conditionner le versement
des aides à l'apprentissage du français
et à la résidence effective de
régionaliser également la cour nationale
du droit d'asile et en conséquence
d'avoir un système régionaliser efficace
permettant de désengorger les centres de
contrôle et les allocations tant que
tout ça n'est pas fait c'est cautère sur
jambe de bois et pas plus aujourd'hui
que demain monsieur que l'on n'arrivera
à rentrer dans les associations et à
vérifier quoi que ce soit et tout le
monde le sait ce que je critique là
dedans c'est une politique qui
paradoxalement est trop molle pour ce
qu'elle a de dur
il ya dans cette danse aussi évidemment
une dimension girier convient d'en
parler aussi une dimension politique
les internautes du figaro ce n'est
évidemment pas un sondage à qui on a
posé la question
certes elle est un peu général et
probablement un peu abstraite êtes vous
favorable à un durcissement un
durcissement de la politique
d'immigration
on a 90 % de réponses favorables il
traire le gouvernement là dessus est ce
que comme nous dit hugo il fait une
politique de droite pour affaiblir
wauquiez je pense que wauquiez c'est pas
trop le souci du gouvernement même s'il
regarde un petit peu de loin on a vu la
réponse hier du président de la
république qui était d'ailleurs
cinglante et j'ai jamais vu je crois une
réponse ou si bien imaginer d'ailleurs
parce que ça correspond assez bien que
ces actes les 50 années d'ailleurs lieu
et j'ai trouvé que fallait il fallait
quand même avoir pas mal d'imagination
et là vous restez quoi quoi c'est assez
drôle de voir la droite réagit
aujourd'hui alors que quand on a lu la
tribune qui a écrit monsieur wauquiez
qui est quasiment indigne sur le
président de la république fin octobre
j'ai envie de dire un parc que la balle
au centre
il ya un partout quoi bon pour ce qui
est de la politique je crois qu'il faut
pas il fallait pas trop forcer gérard
collomb pour qui conduit cette politique
là gérard collomb est un homme qui sur
ce plan là si vous voulez et de la même
école que valls de la même école que
15,9 et c'est quelqu'un qui vise évident
sujets régaliens d'hortefeux
sauf que hortefeux il ne fait pas il n'a
pas fait lui on peut imaginer qu'il va
faire parce que évidemment ils veulent
encore flatter un électorat de droite
dont ils ont largement besoin dont
pascal parlais tout à l'heure pour
essayer d'enfoncer un peu plus descoings
dans le front le front de droite
donc ça c'est une chose la deuxième
chose c'est que il a bien sûr raison
alors françois parle en juriste et en
grand connaisseur de la cause asie l'air
mais je crois que si on va au delà
qu'est-ce qu'il faut se dire là dessus
c'est que à aucun gouvernement n'a
réussi à mettre sur pied une politique
face à l'immigration clandestine qui est
une politique qui tient debout
pourquoi parce que ça met en oeuvre
tellement de facteurs et ça il ya
tellement d'acteurs qui sont partie
prenante à la chose il ya d'abord les
pays d'origine et des états les comment
les gouvernements des pays d'origine qui
n'en font qu'à la qu'à leur tête et qui
évidemment ne nous aide absolument pas
dans ce domaine et je sais mais je sais
bien
il faut les payer on devrait peut-être
conditionner l'aide au développement à
certains pays au fait qu'il veut exercer
un contrôle un peu plus étroit ça c'est
la première des choses
la deuxième des choses c'est qu'on peut
parler de quotas et tout ça ça veut rien
dire du tout ces trucs là l'immigration
clandestine et se moquent complètement
des quotas qu'elle soit économique
m la troisième chose c'est comment on
renvoie tous ceux qui sont déboutés du
droit d'asile
on les renvoie pas on les a jamais
renvoyé on a parlé et ça avait fait les
titres de la presse à l'époque de
charters pasqua mais on n'a jamais pu
renvoyer tous ceux qui sont dégoûtés
il ya un moyen pour les renvoyer un seul
moyen qui existe c'est de prendre les
avions de transport de troupes de
l'armée française et de faire marcher
ses avions là pour ramener chez eux et
bien les immigrés en question pourquoi
les gens pas mais parce que les pays
dont les pays de départ
évidemment la nouvelle ne veulent pas à
délivrer
mais il est là le sujet si vous voulez
simplement on va se on n'a jamais réglé
ce sujet alors oui je sais c'est qu'elle
largement exposé il ya quand même il ya
quand même deux choses à dire là dessus
c'est que il ya là dedans un problème je
voyais défiler sur les écrans les
passages à vintimille par exemple
annoncer le nombre de gens qui passent à
la terre les critiques portées avec
l'italie sont des gens de guinée conakry
la guinée conakry n'est pas que je sache
dans une situation de péril politique ou
guerrier qui justifie un afflux asilaire
je vous insistez quand même pas souci
d'honnêteté sur notre responsabilité
c'est à dire que voici près de 20 ou 30
ans que nous avons les liens les plus
étroits avec des régimes africains tous
plus infects les uns que les autres dans
lesquels on sait que les dirigeants se
mettent qui la rendent du cacao qui la
rendent du bois dans les fouilles chez
lombard odier
et pour le reste n'en font pas profiter
leurs peuples et ensuite touche ce qui a
pu dans le cas de la guinée conakry du
président jusqu aux douaniers leur dîme
par rétrocession des passeurs pour
envoyer les gens chez nous sert que je
comprends très bien qu'ils sa pose de
grandes difficultés mais j'aurai une
objection morale à est trop comment dire
moins dur avec les goûts avec les
dirigeants de ces pays inepte qu'on ne
l'ait qu'avec les pauvres gens qui après
tout viennent chercher chez nous une vie
simplement descendre ce que vous et moi
fleuriot 1a place si on était dans la
même situation
certes ce qui me choque dans cette
affaire c'est ça ce qui me choque en
deuxième lieu et je crois qu'il faut le
dire aussi c'est un arpent de xénophobie
kim est apparu très très clairement
quand j'ai regardé les dispositions de
la loi de sortie de l'état d'urgence
notamment celles visant le contrôle
administratif aux frontières celle qui a
été voté
dont on sait très bien quand on connaît
les statistiques 99% on débouche en
réalité sur des poursuites pour
infraction à la législation du séjour et
non pas sur des poursuites pour
terrorisme
je vais être encore plus précis nous
avons un gouvernement qui en réalité ne
lutte pas en pratique contre la
progression d'un islamisme radical même
nom terroristes dans nos banlieues et
qui en même temps laisse croire que tout
ce qui peut se passer de mal vient de
ces étrangers qu'il faudrait contenir à
l'extérieur je comprends que ça soit son
option tactique cette option paraît
politiquement dangereuse et moralement
blâmable pascal perrineau réaction d'un
internaute guillaume avec 9% de chômage
est un défi identitaires et sécuritaires
comment peut-on prenez un accueil
inconditionnel ce qui évidemment n'est
pas le cas du gouvernement c'est le
manque en plus des noms le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'il n'ya pas
d'accueil inconditionnel d'ailleurs avec
les présidents précédents non plus il
faut par an construire le passé
simplement il y a en effet dans
l'opinion publique française quand vous
regardez une demande qui aujourd'hui est
majoritaire de rigueur
de durcissement sur le terrain de
l'immigration et plus largement des gens
sur le terrain de l'autorité c'est clair
et net
et ça vient pas simplement de
l'électorat delà de la droite ça vient
d'un lectorat du centre et sa touche une
partie tout à fait significative de
l'électorat de gauche dont le ministre
de l'intérieur d'ailleurs monsieur
gérard collomb est tout à fait
représentatif mais il était maire de
lyon socialiste mais il ya un risque à
terme pour je crois emmanuel macron les
forces politiques qui le soutiennent
parce que lorsque emmanuel macron vite
et lui lorsque la république en marche
connaît aux législatives de juin
le succès que l'on sait c'est sûr au
fond de thèmes une gauche qui s'ouvre au
libéralisme économique donc les
positions de libéralisme économique et
social et des positions de ce qu'on
appelle le libéralisme culturel sa
clientèle quand vous regardez les
attitudes des électeurs de la république
en marche ce sont les électeurs qui avec
les électeurs écologistes mais ça n'est
plus grand chose aujourd'hui sont les
électeurs les plus favorables à une
attitude d'ouverture vis-à-vis des flux
migratoires
ce sont des gens qui sont sur des
positions libertaire et non pas du
moteur
mais bien sûr et là il y a le risque
pour emmanuel macron s'il laissait
complètement la bride sur le cou à son
ministre de l'intérieur gérard collomb
de rentrer en contradiction avec une
partie non négligeable de sa base
électorale qui n'est pas du tout sur les
positions de gérard collomb donc il y as
certainement je veux dire il plus prudes
parce que pour l'instant on parle de
quoi on parle de projet ce n'est pas le
projet de loi tel qu'il sera et je crois
qu'il y a comme comme assez souvent
depuis son élection mme emmanuelle
macron lance un ballon d'essai il
regarde comment ça réagit dans la
société et ensuite il a juste et je
crois qu'il en sera de même sur ce
dossier de la question migratoire je
suis totalement incorrect parce que ce
qui est très caractéristique c'est que
l'asile l'asile un truc qui datent
béraud a quand même une porte de l'asie
la femme de paris asie l'asile c'est
quoi le nos francs 1 ces fronts de nos
francs de nature c'est ça gérer le pays
dans lequel on peut devenir libre
donc l'asile évoque pour tous les
français de droite comme de gauche
une notion au quasi religieuse avant
d'être républicaine qui va très au delà
du contrôle des flux migratoires par le
ministre de l'intérieur
il ya donc là un enjeu symbolique très
fort et je ne suis pas du tout sûr qu'il
finisse par arbitrer dans le sens du
projet initial sans doute en partie mais
pas en totalité
jacques et moi paradoxalement il me
semble que c'est la fermeté du
gouvernement actuel sur certains points
qui permettra à l'humanité qu'on
souhaite tous autour de cette table
c'est un accès la fermeté avec les
migrants économiques qui effectivement
ne vous parliez tout à l'heure avec la
guinée conakry mais on pourrait parler
de tous et ce pays d'afrique de l'ouest
qui ne fuit pas une misère de guerre
mais une misère purement économique
et c'est parce qu'on a reçu trop de ces
gens-là qu'on n'arrive pas à accueillir
décemment ceux qui le méritent
réellement et que leur dossier reste
pendant 14 18 20 mois au lieu d'être
traités dans quelques mois et qui sont
et ce qu'ils se retrouvent effectivement
à la rue dans des foyers sociaux donc je
pense que le fermeté avec c'est à dire
que les obligations de quitter le
territoire français les oqtf doivent
être vraiment respectée pour permettre à
ceux qui ont effectivement un droit
d'asile tout à fait légitime d'être
traité avec l'humanité qui est qu'il
méritait que et dont la france s'honore
il ya des révolutions culturelles opéré
dans ces pays d'afrique de l'ouest dont
vous parlez que je connais bien parce
que vous savez que dans une famille il y
en a toujours un dans la famille qui
doit partir justement en france pour et
sont délaissés par une raison pour ne
pas les expulser s'il mérite d'être
expulsés via sûr mais il faut aussi
faire en sorte de changer leur culture
là bas pour qu'ils arrêtent d'envoyer
chaque phrase émane de le faire quand on
a ce qu'on fait seulement parce que l'on
parle d'un sujet plus léger sans doute
même s'il va peut-être inquiéter un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques
dans un sondage ifop publié ce matin
dans le figaro
on a posé cette question certes un peu
artificiel mais qui permet d'avoir un
petit peu l'état de l'opinion
si les élections européennes avaient
lieu dimanche prochain pour quelle liste
y aurait-il le plus de chances que vous
votiez d'accord pour que vous vous
fassiez merci m et la république en
marche s'est allié au modem on peut dire
écrase tout 26% des voix derrière le
front national s'en sortirait à peu près
avec 17 % derrière la france insoumise
les républicains sont donc assez
largement distancé avec 12% d'intentions
de vote
quant au parti socialiste il est
carrément à 8%
un mot de commentaires sur ce sondage
par celui qu'il a effectuée frédéric
dabi le directeur général adjoint de
l'ifop
le premier enseignement de cette
première enquête européenne à 18 mois du
scrutin c'est qu'elle s'inscrit en
continuité avec le big bang électorale
qu'a connue le pays à la présidentielle
et aux élections législatives
ça monte les difficultés du front
national marine le pen perd 25% de ses
électeurs présidentielle et des
élections européennes de 2014 où elle
était arrivée en tête
la france a soumises peine à incarner
une alternative à la république en
marche même si elle est dominante à
gauche par rapport au parti socialiste
et puis on voit avec cette enquête le
les défis à relever pour le révoquer l'
enquête a été faite avant son nez laisse
avant son élection il ya un problème
très sérieux de rassemblement du peuple
de droite qui a un niveau très important
et séduit par la transformation promise
par e-mail macron et l'intègre marche
pascal perrineau le parti de babar et
grâce toute cette dimension de babar sur
la scène électorale
en effet bon il y à quelque chose qui
est intéressant nous sommes loin il faut
être prudent d'abord nous sommes loin du
moins 18 mois nous sommes loin de
l'échéance européenne et donc il ya une
certaine artificialité a recensé
aujourd'hui des intentions de vote mais
ça donne une idée des équilibres
politiques aujourd'hui et on voit très
bien que le capital électoral d'emmanuel
macron n'a pas maigri il a grossi
légèrement mais il a grossi surtout si
vous rajoutez les
adjuvants centriste vous apercevez en
effet qu'il ya une position dominante
mais enfin regarder les listes
eurosceptiques ou europhobes voilà ça
fait du 40 % c'est-à-dire qu'on reste
sur un rapport de force électoral où il
reste en france vis-à-vis de la question
européenne
un très fort scepticisme on pourrait se
mettre d'accord sur ce terme qui peut
rassembler parfois plus que du
scepticisme de l'hostilité la
construction européenne telle qu'elle
s'est telle qu'elle s'est développée
deuxième leçon ce qui est intéressant
c'est l'effondrement de la droite la
droite encore lorsqu'elle est battu le
capital électoral de françois fillon
c'est 20% là il se retrouve à 12% c'est
la décrue en quelques mois la plus
importante
cela montre l'ampleur du travail de
reconquête électorale que le nouveau
patron des républicains va avoir à
opérer parce que du côté des autres
forces lui il ya des érosions mais ce ne
sont pas des effondrements
là on a un maul qui s'effondre c'est la
droite et on revient à ce que l'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
le travail de sa politique et électoral
de la droite depuis six mois à payer et
c'est ce sondage sur les intentions de
vote le montre de manière évidente il ya
toute une série d' électeurs de droite
qui aujourd'hui se retrouveront sans
aucun problème dans un vote pour une
liste nationale la république en marche
ça sera tout l'électorat de la droite à
les europhiles produits dont les twittos
ce qui me suivre donnez votre avis vous
aussi est-ce que vous souhaiter une
victoire de la république en marché aux
européennes exprimez vous sur #cop15 du
hashtag figaro live yves thréard lycéens
ont simplement je pense que les
élections à venir mais on va voir
effectivement ce n'est pas encore tout
de suite et de l'eau peut couler sous
les ponts se souvient qu'en 2005 à un an
et demi du référendum je crois que le
oui était donné
gagnant à 60 ou 75 % donc il ya encore
de la marge
non ce qui va être intéressant c'est de
voir combien cette échéance électorale
risque
je dis bien risques ce sera peut-être
pas le cas mais effectivement de
fracture et encore et de mettre en mille
morceaux
les républicains on voit déjà à là
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que vous avez
un discours qui est d'ailleurs je sais
pas quel est le discours sur l'europe
qu'il faut entendre
est ce que c'est un discours un peu
tiède qui nous dit mais si on est
européen mais c'est pas cette europe-là
de wauquiez ou est ce que c'est un un
discours va ça va être très compliqué en
fait le et le par ça va être pareil pour
le parti socialiste c'est à dire que le
parti socialiste et le parti de droite
classique
ces deux parties se sont toujours
fracasser sur la question européenne
donc je on peut redouter pour eux on
peut redouter que l'échéance à venir
eh bien elle soit redoutable parce
qu'ils sont déjà tellement faible que ça
risque encore les affaiblir davantage en
face à lui son allez vous remonter le
moral de la droite française non ses
dirigeants non mais je trouve que ce
sondage effectivement et n'a pas
honnêtement on n'a pas beaucoup de sens
parce qu'on ne sait pas qui sont les
têtes de liste ont cette tête de liste
qui donne la nature qui donne la couleur
de la campagne
et comme le souligne très bien pascal
perrineau a priori donc quand on accuse
quand on ajoute les scores on arrive à
40% de robes sexy eurosceptiques mais on
ne sait même pas quelle sera la ligne
des républicains d'une part et du parti
socialiste si on peut estimer que dans
ces deux partis il y en a peut-être la
moitié qui sera aux sceptiques on arrive
à 50% d'eurosceptiques pour les
élections européennes
donc il est évident que les maths sont
bougés que c'est très difficile de
commenter dès maintenant appartement on
ne sait pas encore une fois quelle sera
la ligne directrice des deux grands
partis traditionnels qui sont effondrés
là les républicains ces fonds ont fait
le parti socialiste fait pas un bond
quantitatif énorme puisqu'il passera 8 %
donc on voit bien que ces deux partis là
ne sont pas encore ne savent pas encore
comment ils vont conduire leurs
compagnes sur les européennes 6 et 6 et
najat vallaud belkacem par exemple qui
dirige
socialistes et virginie calmels ces
républicains en héritier déclaré
contestées oui c'est vrai je me demande
si on peut pas faire une hypothèse qui
va tout faire bondir faire bondir tous
ceux qui nous regardent
je plante si on n'est pas en train de
refermer la parenthèse républicaine en
réalité qu'est ce qui se passe en 1789
il se passe que si des mains et
qu'est-ce qui ce plan mais c'est très
intéressant même qu'est ce qui se passe
en 1989 il se passe en réalité que la
substitution
la suppression d'un mode de légitimité
un autre légitimité cesse d'être hérité
dynastique divine elle devient populaire
et dès lors qu'elle devient populaire
elle donne lieu à un affrontement
dialectique qui voit se succéder la
droite et la gauche dans quelque chose
de tragique qui fait avancer l'histoire
les rares moments de répit dans des
moments de concentration des centres qui
sont d'ailleurs des moments tout à fait
paradoxaux il est clair que l'épisode
bonapartiste par exemple et napoléonien
est un épisode guerrier et expansif et
de la concentration des centres à
l'heure actuelle qu'est ce qui se passe
nous rentrons dans un système où en
réalité la totalité des valeurs
fondamentales ne sont presque plus
critiquée par personne une dose
raisonnable de libéralisme une dose
raisonnable de européisme et est
finalement l'égalité une relative
égalité des droits bref l'interprétation
de la société ne donne pas lieu à cette
brisure qui a été la brisure des années
dès lors il est assez logique qu'on en
revienne à ce système monarchique ou en
réalité
l'acte de gouverner est assurée de
manière quasi administratives et magique
par une personne centrale
soutenu par une masse assez importante
de gens d'opinions variés reproduisant
exactement ce qui se passait dans la
structure politique de la france de la
fin de l'ancien régime
je n'exclus pas que nous soyons à la fin
d'une période dialectique de notre
histoire politique et qu'une grand
nombre de chose à quoi nous assistons ne
procède pas de cette idée parce qu'elle
fait est ce que le professeur à sciences
po adhèrent à cette idée que finalement
la droite et la gauche c'est fini il ya
un espèce de centre dominant qui
s'installe durablement
l'idée de fin de cycle je la partage est
d'ailleurs bien avant les observateurs
modeste que nous sommes
les français pensaient d'eux mêmes ils
savaient en janvier 2017 j'avais dans un
sondage que l'on fait régulièrement à
sciences po chaque année posait la
question est ce que les notions de
droite et de gauche sont encore
pertinentes pour comprendre les causes
la vie politique d'aujourd'hui c'était
72 % de français qui répondait non donc
les français s'en était rendu compte
avant que les observateurs et la classe
politique prenne sans compter c'est un
des éléments structurels fondamental de
l'espace d'emmanuel mâcon qui s'était
pas nous y là dedans parce que emmanuel
macron quelque part ça signe la fin je
ne sais pas c'est long à mourir des
clivages enracinée depuis deux siècles
dans la culture politique française
voilà deux siècles mais voilà donc c'est
encore présent ça travaille mais si vous
voulez ce sont des appartenances son
contenu c'est à dire de plus en plus on
se sent de gauche on se sent de droite
mais de plus en plus ce sont des
allégeances ou non plus beaucoup de
contenu en revanche les questions sur la
place de la france dans l'europe sur la
place de la france dans la
mondialisation sur le rapport aux grands
autres ça ce sont des questions que les
français ressentent comme tel dans leur
vie quotidienne et auquel vous allez
voir de plus en plus dans les années qui
viennent là dessus je suis assez
d'accord avec martin chauffier et vous
allez voir sa licence cette région pour
cette raison ressurgir l'une des grandes
questions qui étaient les questions de
l'inquiéter la question de ma soeur
haylie la question d enracinement
régional et je pense que les questions
fondamentales auxquelles on va être
affrontés dans les années qui viennent
c'est plutôt des questions de ce type
mais moi il me semble que la nouveauté
et la singularité de macron et c'est
pour ça qu'il a réussi c'est de ne pas
avoir fait ni droite ni gauche mais nord
fait droite et gauche parce que je pense
que droite et gauche continue à exister
dans notre société simplement il a
réussi une certaine manière on est tous
les débats convient d'avoir qu'on nous
font comprendre qu'une sorte de synthèse
habile de la droite et de la gauche
alors que tous ses prédécesseurs y
compris les centristes divers moi c'est
ni droite ni gauche ou même l'extrême
droite ou même extrême alors que lui
synthétise les deux je ne sais pas si
c'est une synthèse de la droite et de la
gauche ou une espèce de reconstruction
de ce qui existait dans tempérament
politique français avant l'apparition de
la droite et de la gauche ce qui le
rendrait tout à fait singulier et quand
faisait référence à ce qu'il avait dit
dans
dans le linge dans le 1 c'est exactement
de cela dont il est question
donc on peut tout dire sauf qu'il est
ignorant des causes qui le détermine un
mode conclusion là dessus bah écoute si
on fait la synthèse séquelles des murs
je m'accrochais qui est assez libre il
est très fort alors il nous est très peu
de temps mais ça tombe bien parce que
parce que le sujet dont nous souhaitions
vous entretenir n'est peut-être plus
pertinents nos confrères du parisien a
évoqué parce que c'était un vrai projet
la possible réapparition d'une vignette
automobile pour financer l'entretien des
routes le gouvernement a dit qu'il
n'avait aucun projet dans les tiroirs
alors voici ce que disait pascal
perrineau tout à l'heure on lance
quelque chose qu'il faut c'est non
ouais bon alors est-ce que vous est ce
que vous croyez au démenti
gouvernementale très brièvement ou
est-ce que vous pensez que il ya une
nouvelle taxe qui va nous tomber dessus
alors là c'est plus dur senti que
l'analyse scientifique j'en conviens
mais je crois que le gouvernement
emmanuel macron se rendent compte que le
problème de la pression fiscale reste à
gauche à droite et au centre
un vrai enjeu et qu'il ne s'agit pas
regarder les réactions extrêmement vives
des français vis-à-vis de la fiscalité
locale ils ont vu tout à fait récemment
leurs feuilles d'impôts locaux ils en
ont tiré la conséquence est rajoutée
dans ce contexte un élément qui
accroîtrait la pression fiscale et
serait extrêmement mal venu il ya eu un
petit ballon des saints on retire
discrètement le ballon d'essai c'est ça
aussi faire de la politique
bon c'est la bonne nouvelle de la
journée apparemment nous avons échappé à
un nouvel impôt ça n'est pas si fréquent
dans les prés je vous dis donc
réjouissons-nous françois cyr vous
souhaitiez prendre quelques instants
pour rendre hommage à un grand
fonctionnaire français qui a aussi été
un banquier claude pierre brossolette
voilà est-ce qu'il est apparu par
ailleurs claude pierre brossolette était
le fils de pierre brossolette dont vous
savez qui s'est défenestrée pour éviter
de parler sous la torture
et c'est un homme que j'ai d'ailleurs je
n'ai pas connu mais qui fait partie de
cette génération de hauts fonctionnaires
qui ont en quelque sorte surplomber les
gens de ma génération quand ils ont
décidé de rentrer au service de l'état
il y en avait quelques-uns comme ça que
nous regardions de manière voilà il y
avait lui il y avait il y avait les
frères mangin qui étaient tous les deux
compagnons de la libération il y avait
des personnages tout à fait lorsqu'il
m'a assez bouleversé avec pierre
brossolette
c'est la manière dont on a accueilli sa
mort et ça m'est apparu comme une sorte
de réapparition de l'idéal berne anosy
dans une teinte exupéry sq dans une
france généralement technocratique
pierre brossolette et l inspecteur des
finances qui avait été secrétaire
général de l'elysée sous giscard et
ensuite président du crédit lyonnais
ils avaient toutes les peaux d'âne
possible ils pouvaient voilà et quand il
est mort il ya eu une foule de tweed de
remarques de choses et j'ai simplement
mort de claude pierre brossolette plus
jeune médaillé de la résistance
française puisqu'il avait été arrêté par
la gestapo à la suite de l'arrestation
de son père à l'âge de 14 ans et au fond
j'ai trouvé ça assez bouleversant et à
ses magnifiques que cette vie paraît sur
la fin se trouvait rempli par cet
épisode d'un courage exceptionnel
manifesté à l'âge de 14 ou 15 ans et ça
m'a donné
méditez valent à son père lui-même est
en écoute à bourseul est était le père
de notre consoeur sylvie pierre
brossolette aujourd'hui membre du csa
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre je vous
propose de retrouver dans quelques
instants
jean christophe buisson mais pas tout
seul puisque vous avez jean-christophe
interviewé eric zemmour sur un thème
d'actualité ce qui était johnny hallyday
ont volontairement de johnny hallyday
surtout les ce qui s'est passé autour de
l'enterrement de jénine et notamment les
débats sur la polémique et sur le son
côté fort peu laïcs selon certains de
son de ses obsèques
voilà retrouvez le bellevue comme
toujours un peu clivant en tout cas
affirmé d'eric zemmour sur ce sujet
merci à tous bon soir
[Musique]